لماذا تفعل هذا، ما زلنا
نعلم أن أساتذة الجامعات يقولون إن
الطلاب يقومون بشكل متزايد بقص
ولصق النص الذي تم إنشاؤه بواسطة الذكاء الاصطناعي في
مقالاتهم، وهذا يعني أن
الأساتذة يقولون إنهم لا يقعون في هذا الخطأ وغالبًا ما تكون
هناك ثلاث
هبات واضحة للغاية أولاً  المقال
مثالي بشكل مثير للريبة،
تبدو المقالة التي تم إنشاؤها
بواسطة تقنية GPT وكأنها مكتوبة بواسطة تلميذ كفء للغاية في الصف الثاني عشر،
ولا يحتوي النص الذي تم إنشاؤه باستخدام الذكاء الاصطناعي على أي أخطاء، فهو
يشبه النص اللطيف آليًا، لن
يتحدث أحد بهذه الطريقة في الواقع، هبة أخرى،
لا يحتوي المقال على صوت بشري،
الصوت المدمج  نموذج مثل دردشة GPT
هو صوت محامي امتثال يبلغ من العمر 50 عامًا،
يبدو أنه يفتقر إلى الحيوية،
ليس هناك الكثير من الطلاب الأصيلين، الصوت أو
الخبرة هناك، النص الذي تم إنشاؤه
بواسطة الذكاء الاصطناعي يبدو وكأنه مقال كتبه
شخص ذكي لم يسبق له مثيل  كان
معي فصل دراسي، وغالبًا ما تستشهد مقالات الذكاء الاصطناعي الثالثة
بأبحاث كاذبة، وربما يكون أكبر
شيء يمكن أن تفعله مقالة الدردشة التي تم إنشاؤها بواسطة EPT
هو زعزعة
ثقة المعلم في ما يعرفه عن
المادة المصدر، فهو سيختلق الأشياء
وسينسب الأفكار إليها  الأشخاص
الذين لم يكن من الممكن أن يكون لديهم هذه الأفكار مطلقًا،
سيجمع بين القواعد النحوية المثالية مع
شيء يبدو كاذبًا بشكل واضح،
لا أستطيع التمييز بين الحقيقة
والخيال، لا أستطيع التمييز بين
المعلومات والمعلومات المضللة، سيبدو وكأنه يقتبس
وسيبدو كذلك
الاستشهاد ولكن إذا كانت هذه المصادر
لا تبدو مألوفة بالنسبة لك، فهناك
فرصة جيدة لأن يكون هذا مكتوبًا بواسطة الذكاء الاصطناعي، فهل
يستحق الأمر ذلك حتى لو لم يتم القبض عليك،
هل تريد أن تكون شخصًا يتمتع
بالنزاهة، ولا تدع الذكاء الاصطناعي التوليدي يفعل ذلك
تفكيرك بالنسبة لك قد يفلت
من العقاب ولكنك الوحيد الذي
سيتأذى من ذلك